activités complémentaires le problème
socio économique aujourd'hui le salaire
d'efficience à la base cet exposé vidéo
le principe d'économie de jones lohman à
petit rappel tout d'abord le salaire
selon la théorie classique dépend de
l'offre de travail et de la demande de
travailler comme sur un marché de biens
et de services
il y aura un point d'équilibré qui
pourra donner le taux de salaire deck
libres auxquels bien sûr les entreprises
en situation de concurrence pure et
parfaite devront s'adapter pour pouvoir
engager des travailleurs et les
travailleurs eux-mêmes devons accepter
ce salaire équilibre pour pouvoir
trouver un nom cependant ce modèle
théorique peut être mise en cause par
l'observation de la réalité tout d'abord
nous avons vu que le salaire proposé par
un employeur peut être supérieure à la
suite d'une négociation entre
partenaires sociaux et entreprises et
employeurs mais d'autres économistes et
en plus particulièrement les néo
keynésiens vont mettre en avant le fait
que certaines entreprises vont proposer
un salaire au dessus du niveau équilibre
dans le sens de leurs propres intérêts
c'est ce qu'on va appeler le salaire
déficiences pourquoi est ce que les
entreprises vont proposer un salaire
supérieur c'est parce qu'elles
considèrent que proposait un salaire
supérieur va amener un gain de
productivité et un meilleur roman des
travailleurs par rapport à l'activité
économique mis en place
mais comment peut-on expliquer cette
relation entre un salaire élevé et une
augmentation de la productivité
il y a trois éléments de réponse que
nous développerons successivement dans
la vidéo tout d'abord la réduction des
comportements non corner non coopératifs
mais aussi la réduction de la rotation
de la main de
et enfin la motivation des salariés
voyons ici c'est différent quoi pour
certaines tâches il n'est pas très
facile pour l'entreprise de contrôler le
travail fourni par chaque travailleur il
s'agit parfois de tâches complexes qu'il
ne plus qu'ils ne peuvent pas être
vraiment mesuré pour éviter que certains
travailleurs ne soit pas coopératifs et
sabote en quelque sorte le travail de
l'entreprise
l'entreprise peut être amené à mettre en
place différentes sanctions pouvant
aller jusqu'au renvoi définitif mais
plus le salaire du travailleur va être
élevée plus celui ci aura peur de ce
renvoi définitif étant donné que ça lui
coûtera énormément étant donné que ces
revenus sont plus que hbo et donc ils
auront tendance à adopter un
comportement vraiment plus productifs
plus coopératif en étant beaucoup moins
qui ronfle le résultat pour l'entreprise
c'est une augmentation bien sûr de la
productivité des travailleurs mais aussi
une réduction des coûts de contrôle de
ces mêmes travailleurs
il faudra moins les surveiller étant
donné que leurs salaires élevés les
poussera à travailler plus de peur
évidemment de le perdre
le salaire déficience va également
permettre de réduire la rotation
demandeurs
rappelons ici que certains travailleurs
sont formés parlant les entreprises et
donc l'entreprise investit de l'argent
des sommes importantes pour ces
travailleurs dans le cas où un de ces
travailleurs veut quitter l'entreprise
ça va être une perte sèche pour cette
entreprise parce qu'elle aura passé son
temps et de son argent à investir dans
ce travailleur qui finalement ne
travaillera pas très longtemps dans
cette même entre entreprises donc
l'entreprise peut se peut offrir un
salaire plus élevé que celui du marché
pour éviter le départ de ces
travailleurs qualifiés qu'elle a formés
enfin le salaire déficience va jouer sur
la motivation de salariés l'entreprise
peut accorder un salaire supérieur au
taux dé qui pour motiver ce travail
autrement dit elles tentent de
développer une image de bonne employeur
soucieux du bien être de ses salariés en
conséquence les salles arrive et les
employés se montreront plus assidus ils
voudront remercier l'entreprise d'être
si généreuse et si bienveillante à leur
égard et de ce fait ils augmenteront
leur productivité productivité mais
aussi ils accepteront plus facilement
l'introduction de nouvelles technologies
ou une réorganisation du travail qui
changera leur façon de faire à laquelle
il était attaché
l'hypothèse du salaire déficience n'est
valable que pour certains types de
travail le salaire déquilibre
s'appliquera plus tôt pour des
travailleurs peu qualifiés facilement
remplaçable et qui procède qui réalise
détache facilement contrôlable tandis
que le salaire déficience lui sera
plutôt proposé aux travailleurs
qualifiés et hautement qualifiés qui
soient formées ou non par l'entreprise
mais plus ils seront formés par
l'entreprise évidemment plus auront de
chance de recevoir un salaire
déficiences et envoie aussi ce salaire
déficience sera d'application pour les
profils très très rare qu'il est
difficile à trouver sur le marché du
travail
cette vidéo est maintenant finie alors
avant de nous quitter
n'oubliez pas d'écrire et de noter vos
questions afin de les poser vos cours et
tout de suite vous pouvez passer au quiz
qui va vérifier l'acquisition de ses
avoirs
bonne fin de journée et à bientôt